es herrscht Anspannung in
perushauptstadt Lima die Polizei ist in
Alarmbereitschaft patrouliert in den
Straßen mit schwerem Gerät der Grund die
Protestwelle aus dem Süden des Landes
hat die Hauptstadt erreicht
tausende sind aus den entlegenen
andengebieten ins politische Zentrum
Perus geströmt sind wütend auf die
Regierung
[Musik]
viele hier haben ihre Kinder oder ihre
Familien verlassen wir sind hier weil
wir dafür kämpfen dass unser Land uns
nicht weiter mit Füßen tritt damit
Gerechtigkeit und Gleichberechtigung für
alle gelten
seit Wochen machen die Proteste in Peru
international Schlagzeilen vor allem
wegen der Brutalität der Polizei und 50
Menschen wurden getötet in einem Drittel
des Landes gilt der Ausnahmezustand
studentenführerin leonella labra nimmt
uns mit hinter die Kulissen der Proteste
was aussieht wie eine riesen-wg ist ein
geheimer Rückzugsort in Lima für 100
Demonstranten wie fast alle hier stammt
die 23-Jährige leonella aus dem
ländlichen Süden Perus wo viele aus
indigenen Volksgruppen in Armut leben
vor allem diese indigenen sind es die
sich jetzt gegen die Präsidentin erheben
seit ihrem Antritt hat sie mehr
Todesfälle als Tage im Amt zu
verzeichnen
seit die Proteste angefangen haben hat
die Präsidentin mit ihren Kabinett
zusammen Demonstranten unterdrücken und
Menschen ermorden lassen
die politische Lage ist kompliziert
Auslöser für die Unruhen war der Streit
um den linksgerichteten Präsidenten
Petro castigo eher der selbst aus einer
ländlichen Bauernfamilie stammt war für
die Menschen aus dem Süden zur Ikone
geworden sollte Ihnen als Präsident
endlich eine Stimme geben doch nach
miserabler Regierungsbilanz mit
wöchentlichen kabinettsumbildungen und
Korruptionsvorwürfen geht kastilo zu
weit als er eine Misstrauensantrag
zuvorkommen und das Parlament auflösen
will setzen die Abgeordneten kurze Hand
Ihnen ab jetzt sitzt er wegen eines
versuchten Staatsstreichs in
Untersuchungshaft
neue Präsidentin ist sie die bisherige
vizedina boluate die ist zwar in
derselben Partei wie Castillo wird aber
von indigenen Bauern und linken Gruppen
abgelehnt steht für das verhasste
Hauptstadt ist Tablet dazu ist sie
verantwortlich für die massive
Polizeigewalt gegen die Demonstranten
ihre Regierung unbedingt
aufrechterhalten und zwar nicht allein
durch politische Bündnisse und
Verhandlungen sondern durch die Nähe zu
Militär und Polizei
das Problem dabei ist dass wir in Peru
eine Polizei haben die weder gut
ausgebildet ist noch über ausreichende
Ressourcen verfügt um einen Konflikt wie
den aktuellen zu bewältigen
welche Konsequenzen das hat zeigen uns
die Demonstranten
darauf sieht man Menschen die gestorben
sind in einer cucho und Cusco
ist die Liste der Menschen die bei den
Protesten im Süden des Landes ermordet
wurden hier sind die Fotos
am ermordet sie benutzen Geschosse in
verschiedenen Größen manchmal schießen
Sie uns direkt auf den Körper
wir begleiten leonella labra zur Uni
hier hat die Bewegung ein spendenlager
mit Essen und Trinken aber auch
Gasmasken und Helmen die Forderungen der
Demonstranten Rücktritt der Präsidentin
Freilassung des Ex-Präsidenten und
sofortige Neuwahlen für einen Rücktritt
sind laut Umfragen auch 70% der Peruaner
die Präsidentin selbst lehnt das ab
sofortige Neuwahlen oder mein Rücktritt
das würde nur noch mehr Chaos
verursachen die Demonstranten denken gar
nicht an all die Probleme die durch
diese gewalttätigen Proteste entstehen
doch selbst wenn sich das politische
Personal ändern würde das zugrunde
liegende Problem Perus ist die gleich
mehrfach gespaltene Gesellschaft
so ist das Land zum Beispiel der
zweitgrößte Kupferproduzent der Welt
doch bei den Menschen im Süden wo die
Minen sind kommt kaum etwas von den
Profiten an
während in Lima neue Hochhäuser
entstehen gibt es in vielen Dörfern
nicht einmal fließendes Wasser die
Schere zwischen Stadt und Land reich und
arm in die gehen und nicht in die gehen
sorgt für Spannungen
sozial wirtschaftlich und territorial
und was der aktuelle Konflikt deutlich
macht ist einer dieser Brüche nämlich
die tiefe politische soziale und
wirtschaftliche Kluft zwischen einem
Teil des Landes nämlich Lima und der
Nordküste und andererseits dem gesamten
Süden der Anden mit seinen indigenen
es gibt keine einfache Lösung für diesen
Konflikt
ich spreche lieber über den Beginn einer
Lösung
wir fahren durch einen Tunnel
im Moment ist es dunkel
die Wahlen können das Licht sein lass
uns irgendwann einen Ausweg zeigen kann
doch selbst über den Wahltermin gibt es
zwischen Präsidentin Kongress und
Demonstranten bisher keine Einigkeit so
dürften die Proteste von indigenen wie
leonella labra gegen die Staatsgewalt
weitergehen bis zu einem echten
gesellschaftlichen Frieden für Peru ist
es noch ein weiter Weg